KORY JEFFREY: Welcome everybody.
We're on site at Founder
World in San Francisco.
I'm joined in the studio
today by Kris Gale, co-founder
of Clover Health.
Kris, thank you for joining me.
KRIS GALE: Hi, yeah.
Thanks for having me.
KORY JEFFREY: So we were talking
just before camera started
rolling about the
really cool stuff
that you're doing in
the health care space.
Can you kind of elaborate
what Clover Health is and some
of the innovations that
you're bringing to the market.
KRIS GALE: Yeah, absolutely.
So Clover Health is a
health insurance startup.
But what we're
doing is using data
about our members to figure out
the specific moments in time
where we have an opportunity
to intervene in their care,
and actually prevent them
from having adverse health
consequences down the road.
So for things like, if
we have a member who's
managing a chronic
disease-- say,
congestive heart failure--
we're looking for opportunities
for specific care
follow ups, or tests,
or interventions with
the member that we know
will reduce their probability
of having all the adverse health
consequences that are
associated with that disease.
KORY JEFFREY: So
for the developers
who are watching,
how does that work?
How do you do that?
KRIS GALE: Yeah, so we take
all these raw data points--
we're an insurance company.
So we can see historical claims.
Claims have diagnoses
associated with them, treatments
and procedures.
And they're all
encoded as numbers.
So then we have to match those
up through concept ontologies
to be able to say, this
person took this drug.
We know this to be an
oral diabetes medication.
Or they had this test.
And we know that
it's an indication
of how well they've controlled
their blood sugar up
to this point.
And then we can
say, OK, well now
we can assemble a clinical
profile of the person who
has all those raw data
points associated with them.
So we know this is, for example,
a high risk type 2 diabetic.
And we know the appropriate
clinical standards
for managing that disease.
And we can see the
care they're actually
receiving from their doctors,
hospitals, specialists.
And we can identify
the missing pieces,
and then go out with our own
staff of nurse practitioners.
And while they're in that
encounter with that member,
they're using applications
that we've written to say,
while you're interacting
with this member,
make sure you do this one thing.
Because we know the quantitative
effect on their health
probabilities for you
filling this care gap
at this moment in time.
KORY JEFFREY: So
that obviously has
a lot of upside
for the individual,
but also seems to have a lot
of upside for the insurance
company as well.
KRIS GALE: Yeah, exactly.
And that's why we chose to
do this as a health insurance
company, because we're
on the hook for paying
for really expensive
hospitalizations
if they happen.
So our financial incentives
are aligned with the health
incentives of our members.
And as we're improving
their quality of life,
we're actually saving
costs for ourselves.
So we think it's a really well
aligned way of managing health.
KORY JEFFREY: How new
is this in the space?
Do you guys see that you guys
are the only people doing this?
Are there people
now following along?
What's the space like?
KRIS GALE: The space
is largely people
who are trying to
do pieces of this.
I think we're sort
of best positioned
to do this comprehensively,
because we are an insurance
company who also has this
data science and software
development function.
I think a lot of people
are building similar tools
to the ones we've
built, and they're
trying to sell them into
insurance companies.
But it sits alongside
six or seven
other IT tools they're using.
It's not sharing data
among those things.
And they're missing these
opportunities, then,
to actually drive operational
behavior changes, because all
they can do is sell software.
We think we're doing it
all together in one room.
And we think that's
the novel part.
KORY JEFFREY: And so an
insurance company with a very
cool, holistic tech bend to it.
What draws you to a
place like Founder World?
KRIS GALE: I think what's
interesting about events
like this is seeing all of the
other things that are starting
to happen in the space, and
potentially find other health
tech startups that are doing
things that will produce
improved disease outcomes,
and then looking at Clover
as potentially a
platform to go out and be
a customer for those things.
Because we'll invest in any
technology that we can show
improves the clinical quality
outcomes of our members.
So we think we're
the ideal customer
for a lot of the people
who might be exhibiting
at an event like this.
KORY JEFFREY: And so you
were a speaker today.
What was it you
were talking about?
What was the message
you were trying
to get across to everybody?
KRIS GALE: Yeah,
largely it was this.
It was about the state of
the health care vertical,
and what entrepreneurs
and people looking
to get into this space should
know about who buys what.
What are their incentives?
What are the changing regulatory
dynamics of health care?
KORY JEFFREY: So as
you look at-- obviously
we talked about you
investing in anything that
makes sense for the incentives.
Is there any one space
from a health care
point of view that looks
particularly promising?
Is it VR?
Is it big data?
Is it anything like that?
KRIS GALE: Yeah,
for me, I think it's
a lot of stuff related
to behavioral health.
So we're ensuring a population
of seniors, 65 and older,
who might be on a lot of
medication simultaneously.
And it's very difficult
if you're also
managing maybe depression, or
other behavioral health issues,
to stay adherent to your
medication schedule.
So a lot of people are coming
up with different tools
where maybe it's a smartphone
app, or a smart pill bottle,
or things that help people to
take their medication on a more
regular schedule.
We know that improves
health outcomes.
So we're looking at
potentially being
a customer for those
sorts of things,
because we can measure
whether it's actually
working for our
members, and continue
to deploy the technology
that actually helps.
KORY JEFFREY: OK.
That's really cool too, because
you could actually prove out
the model for the startups
as well, because you
have the holistic system.
Awesome.
So speaking of
technology, do you
have a favorite
Google technology?
KRIS GALE: Yes, I've
been using Inbox lately.
Yes, I'm a huge fan of Inbox.
Just within the last
couple months rolled out
for our enterprise account.
So I love it.
KORY JEFFREY: So do
you find the paradigm
shift hard to get used to, or
are you just easy to pick up?
KRIS GALE: I think it
took a couple weeks for me
to get to Inbox Zero
and start to use that.
But being able to defer
something and say I'll
get to this tomorrow morning
and clear it out of my inbox,
and just always be managing
the things that come through.
One of the things I
find is that my job
as a co-founder in
this business is
to really be up on
top of things and make
sure I'm not blocking anyone
in the organization that's
waiting on me for an answer.
So being able to have that sort
of optimization for cycle time,
that I think Inbox does a
really good job of for me.
KORY JEFFREY: Yeah, I know.
I'm kind of cheating right now.
I have both Inbox and Gmail.
And so I've got kind of
one foot in both camps.
And that doesn't work
well all the way around.
KRIS GALE: I went
completely over to Inbox.
The second I used
it, I was 100% in.
KORY JEFFREY: You
have inspired me.
I'm going to have to do it.
Well, thank you very
much for joining.
KRIS GALE: Yeah,
thanks for having me.
KORY JEFFREY: Awesome.
And thank you guys for joining.
This is site at Founder
World in San Francisco.
[MUSIC PLAYING]